Tennyson your article a screenwriter
prepares one of the tidbits you offer is
that a screenwriter needs to take acting
lessons respond please oh boy yeah I
talked to a lot of writers who really
really object to that perspective um and
I will say that one of the things we
talked about earlier in this interview
was the idea that a lot of films fall
short when it comes to the establishment
of drama when it comes to focusing very
specifically on what an actor is doing
what their action is and then focusing
on all the other actions of all the
other characters that make that action
untenable you know though the question
of you know like we were saying Luke
Skywalker wants to save the universe and
liberated and Darth Vader wants to
enslave the universe and destroy it and
you just you don't get to have it both
ways every great story revolves around
conflicting interests and the
follow-through the actual pursuit of
those interests and when you spend four
hours a day for 10 years doing that
finding finding what action it is that
you're taking and then executing it to
its conclusion to the fullest extent
with the most commitment you can
possibly have following it through so
that there is no doubt that every
possible option every every chance at
success has been exploited and you have
completely burned out for success or
failure for better or for worse and
hitting your head against every
challenge that comes up along the way
you know what I mean hitting your head
against all the other actors who are
doing things that get in your way
hitting your head against your Darth
Vader you know again and again and again
and ever having it be the same impulse
always trying something new always
trying something different I'm gonna try
this well I'm gonna try that just like
football trying to get across the field
and every time boom you know i'm gonna
kick it no you're not sucker
now kicking that ball that's that's what
makes a film great you know a minority
report going back to steven spielberg
and tom cruise watch the sequence where
it's one of the most elevated special
effects sequences of our time people
think of it as like high science fiction
with all these effects shots when he's
jumping from car to car and the cars are
going up the wall he's gonna plummet and
he's trying to get off the highway you
know the seen him do with the magnetic
cars there we know what I'm talking
about he's guys know what I'm talking
about so Oh anyways he's jumping there's
these cars that travel on magnetic rails
and he jumps from car to car because
he's stuck in the car cuz there's a
little robot in the car that's taking
him or he doesn't want to go and he's
trapped so he kicks the thing and in the
car goes whoosh of a building and it's
upside down because it's on the magnetic
rail it's not really a street it's just
attached to this rail it's going all
around the city and turning and he's
literally outside the car trying to stay
on top of whatever it is he's standing
on so he can jump in the next car jump
to the next car and then get off the
freeway before he is squashed / plummets
to his grisly doom one of those two
things and it's a very exciting sequence
and most of the time you're watching his
eyes most of the shots are of him doing
like like trying to time where that next
car is trying to figure out when he's
going to jump it's only when you're like
why are you so focused Tom Cruise that
the camera pulls back and shows you that
in fact there's like thousands of feet
for him to fall and probably something
is going to smash into a moving at a
hundred miles an hour and as soon as
that message is across we get back to
Tom Cruise figuring out when he's going
to jump on any jumps like the shot is
not about the city and the carbs the
shot is about Tom Cruise try to get off
the damn freeway and it's only to
establish the stakes that you pull back
at all when Iron Man is screaming
through the sky you're mostly watching
his face inside the mask and he's like
and then like why are you so happy I
man oh that's why you're so happy he's
trying to fly his robot suit you know
and you see him in the robot suit before
you see him in the robot suit is just
there to explain like here's why it's so
cool here's why robert downey jr's
having such a goddamn good time i would
too I get that and then we're back
inside the Sunnis problem-solving he's
trying to figure out the next thing why
is this suit icing up what if what am I
going to do next to solve this problem
that i have that is the only thing that
special effects do they justify the
action of the actor it all starts with
the screenwriting if you are focusing on
anything else you are making your movie
worse so I think that I think that
screenwriters should take acting classes
because they would do that they would
just get into their body it's get into
their heads and make it a little bit
more impulsive and a little bit less a
little bit less a thing that you have to
do this readers might look for
you